I rubbed some people the wrong way by
trying to break out by trying to do what
I had learned and what I considered the
best I could do I think fear is a
motivator you have to know that you will
never be perfect but you can't believe
it
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from Academy
award-winning actor Benicio del Toro and
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well enjoy
we're just interested in being really
you know almost like a guest at
someone's house I don't wanna like you
know I don't want to move the table just
yeah I behave it really well
when it comes to the approach to my
character it wasn't until a little bit
later that I realized that everything
that I've learned and I put all this
time in class that needed I needed to
let that out I needed to I need it to
grow so it wasn't until a movie I did
call I think it's called fearless
it's a Peter weird film that I really
want I'm gonna bring in everything that
I've learned and tried to make it play
she'll be right now you do this mm-hm
the carven yeah a little bit of playing
you know and by that I mean I'm gonna be
from the superficial from the Wardrobe
to the the character and make an
interpretation I'm gonna make an
interpretation about this guy I'm gonna
look at the guy and I'm gonna say I'm
gonna I'm gonna make an interpretation
and then I'm gonna try to have moments
where I can show things that together
makes an interpretation I rubbed some
people the wrong way by trying to break
out by trying to do what I had learned
and what I considered the best I could
do and I rubbed him the wrong way
I rubbed some people yes the wrong way
but he was taking chances and it was
paying off in 1995 he was cast as
Fenster in a movie called the usual
suspects satalia he had an idea
del Toro thought this character would be
better if he essentially mumbled through
the movie oh I don't want about the hook
of it uh dysentery
it was risky but it worked and it became
Benicio Del
Rose breakout role I went out on a limb
playing a character that was on the
borderline of showboating or or being
really like over-the-top and the fact
that the movie worked
I think people consider it a
breakthrough in my career and I
recognize that as well it was the moment
because the movie was on point it became
what it had to become I remember the day
I finished shooting that film I was so
depressed I felt i overacted I felt I
there was the end of my career you know
I felt okay you know I dared and I tried
to do this character but there was this
feeling of like it what a what a big
mistake I should have played it in a
different way and all the other actors
were so themselves and Here I am I am
you know and so I I was really it was it
wasn't like oh yeah I did the great part
and here we go and my career is just
gonna take off and it's not like that
you get intimidated by roles do you ever
think I'm not sure I can do it or is
that a turn-on
I I think fear is a motivator I think I
think yeah I think I think I'm a even
you know even even
it doesn't matter what role is getting
in front of that camera it's a little
bit intimidating and there's always that
I feed from those butterflies you know
the first day in school or you know
right before tip-off being on stage
giving a speech to an audience or
whatever and it does butterflies I need
them I need to yeah and I doesn't matter
what rule it is if there's always a
sense of and if fear might not be the
right word but but it there is an
element of fear that motivates as your
attorney aversive events a very fast car
with no top and you'll need to cocaine
have you ever struggled to to find a
character have you ever gotten closer
and closer to set and had it hadn't had
it yet you know I don't think I ever
find him you know it just keeps evolving
yeah you know I always feel like I
always you know to be honest with you I
always feel like I get the closest I can
get to the character on the last day of
shoot you know you know one thing is
like that you that kind of like it kind
of like that I wish I'd good yarn
earlier because I used to beat myself
for that nothing is perfect
absolutely nothing is perfect so so you
know so yeah you know I struggle with
that I I what I try to do and maybe the
only the only maybe medicine for that
might be you know put as much time as
you can before you do it right yeah work
as hard as you can while you're doing it
has stayed focused no matter if you have
good days or bad days you know how much
maybe that's that's that's the medicine
I try to just to go state is to keep my
hands on it it's there You've anybody if
this is a disaster and I feel it's at
this a I just don't let go if you cross
this line
you better be ready to kill me I think
Trust is very very important between
actors I think that's that's something
that helps you or encourages you to to
feel free to dare to and also I would
say to impress you know I think that
there's something about and I think
every actor feels like that I can't be
the only one but I've never really
mentioned it before but there's
something else then I feel like I wanna
I want to have let's say I want to have
Tim Robbins go that was really good
oh yeah that was really good there's
something about the actor and that you
also want to impress that other actor
that you admire and even if it's an an
actor you haven't worked with before
there is then then the approach might be
different you know it depends you know
if it's an actor that is that you that
has worked before and and you don't you
don't know their work but so then
there's more of like a friendship you
know starting that friendship even if
your character hates that character the
character the other actor is planck's so
so it's important to have that
fraternity and and inevitably as an
actor and knowing how difficult it is to
get in front of them of that thing it's
it's it's you you can't help it but feel
for some kind of friendship or or or you
know with the other actor you can't help
it you know like like we're both in this
confusing thing and we can only figure
it out this confusing thing if we work
together if we don't we'll never figure
it out
so so you have to work together I don't
know if you know this but me and Benicio
started acting school together
nothing and and I even watched him and I
and I saw him and I yeah you could see
which happens tella and I could see the
talent flying off him and I said to
myself I'll never do it I'll never be
able to do that I'll never be able to do
one thing I remember about him is that
what I was I came from San Diego I quit
college and got this to go to still
Adler and they're by the way one day I
asked him what are you doing tonight and
he goes I I gotta go home and I said
won't you come out he goes well I gotta
like I gotta go to San Diego and I go
like but you say you got to go home and
he was traveling two hours every day
back and forth to go to school and I
knew I knew right away I went like this
kid is strong you know and I and I
always knew you were like you were like
really someone that I just looked up to
so you an actor whose philosophy is to
work or to wait are you more of a like
I'm not going to do anything until I
find the right thing or you're just like
I should be working in no one little bit
of a workaholic but but I can't but I
need to I feel like I like to take my
time I want to be able to select what I
should do I like to explore try to
explore different things different types
of of experiences but movies select you
and by that I mean a director and a
script they are the ones that are going
to throw the party and you want to be
you want to go to the best party you
know we used the metaphor of a party for
a movie so a good director and ask
interesting story will always you know
dominate the choices that I make or
control the choices that I make because
if right now is a great director with an
interesting script comes to me and wants
me to do a character that might not be a
huge stretch but to be involved with a
with a what a team Louise are not made
alone team is teamwork that always will
be like a exciting and might take the
first place a good team might take first
place but I like to take my time but
what I like to work too so you know just
a good balance you know just keep a good
balance I don't think we're waiting -
sometimes it's good to wait because you
get exhausted after doing movies you
know
kind of like you know you I give it give
it a lot of energy so I'm kind of like
exhausted but but you know balance you
know my weight for a little bit and then
do one to two movies almost back-to-back
you need me now more than ever
don't baby so no woman did Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas made after hundred
Thompson's book and that movie didn't do
so well didn't do all that well
critically didn't do all that well into
box office well that's another one of
those glorified failures first of all I
got a chance to spend time with Hunter
as Thompson I'll admire his work I've
mired that book I I read that book maybe
four times back and forth just to
understand it I learned so much about
literature reading that book because it
was the first time that I started seeing
writing as just like acting your
building right and and you have a point
of view and I felt I needed to give my
all to this movie and so did Johnny Depp
and we worked really hard and I gained
weight too and did it by myself like 40
pounds if you can see how I change when
you want license to kill which was maybe
five six years before and then that
movie fear and loathing but I did it by
myself I had no trainer I just I had
eight weeks to do it all I hate was I
found out eating doughnuts eating 16
doughnuts a day you gain 3 to 4 pounds
every day and that's all I did I would
go in eat open the book read the book
call Hunter what is this will tell me
about Oscar Acosta the guy who's dr.
gonzo you know who died before we even
did this movie so I want any 100
Thompson on the phone eating Donuts at
the same time yes when it came time to
lose a lot of weight so you could play
the character che guevara how did you do
that I mean a lot of people would be
interested in how you lose weight yeah
there's no cutting corners on losing
weight you're gonna stop the eating
forget the doughnut
get the doughnuts and only pizza and and
you have to get up and work out we were
doing two maybe three workouts a day do
you think you have to be a perfectionist
to be a good action
you yeah
I think you have to try to be yeah you
have to you gotta try to be perfect but
you have to know that you will never be
perfect
but you can't believe it and you it's
it's a circle in a way but but you can't
like you can't just because if you said
if you you can't lie to yourself but you
have to lie to yourself that makes no
sense
you have to try to do the best you can
you know you have to try you have to I
mean and you know I always wish I had
more time you know like give me another
week and I'll figure this one out
something happens in that room she
should say you didn't see anything my
dad like I remember going to the movies
with my dad watching some clean Eastwood
movies and John Wayne movies and that
was though they were all fun and I liked
the movies like the kid next door you
know but but I I was more like a
basketball that was my sport and then
and I grew up with posters of Kareem
abdul-jabbar and Bill Walton my wall dr.
J but but I was not like oh I gotta go
to the movies and and in high school I
wasn't in the theater program or
anything like that I in high school I
kind of like turn into rock and roll
that was like my thing you know
I took my really my first acting class
was because I wanted to make my my
schedule in college easy it's like I
took an acting class and I said you know
how difficult can that be acting 101 oh
I just
move to San Diego to UCSD you know the
beautiful beach to Harriet like I don't
want to go on study acting oh okay plus
you know all the hot chicks are gonna be
there so I mean all the hot girls they
gonna be there so I that solo was really
out of being a wise guy in a way like
you know cut some corners I took an
acting class and then the teacher said
something that I kind of like stuck with
me he said you know you guys are 18 or
19 years old this is the right age is to
study acting to start starting acting
and I don't really I kind of wanna like
oh you mean that we can take this
serious and a long time you know hmm
and that was and then I started like and
then I really enjoyed it and I'm gonna
like well maybe I should do something
that I really enjoy with my life
you really have fun while I'm working
by the time I'm doing I started going on
auditions I was really like I figured
out there was a logic to acting there
was there's a science to it and uh and I
had study with like I was in a study
with Stella Adler so it was serious and
if you were in that conservatory of
studying with Stella Adler that was a
really serious stuff you know you
couldn't be late you know
I got a scholarship in the school so I
had to know I was doing everything every
class movement boys and all this stuff
so I was really into it
where's my wife don't worry
we gave her a nice honeymoon
why Sicario and why the perfect day
usually first of all I love what I do
and you have to love what you do
otherwise do something else usually is
the story and then the character you
know the like in a perfect day the
character is a little bit different it's
very different from the Sicario
character so we as actors we always look
to to be challenged to try something
different to try different characters
and so those two are different and you
know it's it wasn't the money I wish I
could say was the money but it wasn't
the money what class are you in class
ain't gonna served in 192 countries it's
world famous
like me
[Music]
it happens all the time
[Music]
I told you about their scary movies
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because robbed of goose
asked me to if there's something you'd
like me to cover in a future top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video what lesson really hit home the
hardest what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Sam berry Sam thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting with your
Instagram account I really appreciate
the support man we share the same one
were to believe I love it and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the book thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I enjoy doing little movies and and if I
have the possibility to do big movies
but doing uh doing a big movie can be
fun and I'm doing and but I think that I
started doing independent movies and
it's like you can't forget where you
come from so I will do independent
movies it's sometimes it's easier not
easier but it creatively is you can get
to the boss in a straight line when you
do a studio movie
there are many bosses turn a few hurdles
and yeah there's a lot of turns it
starts to look like London and you get
lost who were you when you got started
who who were you modeling yourself after
who who were the the people that that
you're like I want that there's like
there's like three three stages of it
there's like there's like when before I
was an actor mm-hmm when I started going
to movies there were three was I like
movies of Robert De Niro movies an Eddie
Murphy had movies of Richard Gere Wow
so those were like the guys that I kind
of like look you know before I started
acting and I was already going to the
movies on my own and then after when I
started acting then it was like you know
then it was Pacino
you know Marlon Brando then I started
discovering Humphrey Bogart and lot of
actors you know Anthony Quinn
a lot of actors that are not around
anymore they still moved me you know
they're I I can watch you know a good
Anthony Quinn movie or a Brando movie
you know it's just like I just I just
can't watch it now and black one doesn't
bug me but that's you know and then
there were other young actors that we're
doing stuff that really kind of like
were a bit more contemporary like Sean
Penn Gary Oldman
they were doing this like they were
going out there and taking chances and
that's when I started acting that's what
like oh those were like actors that I
kind of like how come I want to mold it
ya know you know you know like that
or like like their pattern I sometimes
feel like I'm I get distracted really
quick like but then sometimes I embrace
the distraction because the distraction
might take me somewhere that I never
thought I would go for that but let's
say I'm supposed to be here working on
this scene or whatever and then
something pops up on TV and that takes
me away and it takes me somewhere else
and then I'm out the window
and then I'm looking at something
outside the window that come bringing me
back to the script like going like oh
there's someone walking out of a car
with an umbrella
there you go I should have an umbrella
in that scene because it's raining
and if the distraction took me there the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon they believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]